hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today we're going to
be going over the loli attack it's been
one of my most requested videos it's
very similar to the fried liver attack
which many people enjoy playing but it
actually plays a little bit better it
scores a little bit better as far as
competition wise White has a phenomenal
win rate so I thought it would be a good
idea to go over it it's not covered too
much on the internet so I thought it
would be a good idea to actually put
something out there to show you guys
some some things to think about and some
different ideas as far as variations in
the loli attack so it starts out with
pawn to e4 pawn e5 Knight f3 simple
development again trying to control the
center of the board with as minor pieces
Knight to c6 again simple development
move from black trying to control the
turn the board the same thing
transforming into the Italian game with
Bishop to c4 trying to eye down on this
f7 Square a huge weakness for black
early on into the game and from there
blacks going to continue with the two
Knights defense with Knight to f6 and
then White's going to play Knight to f5
here now blacks going to block this by
playing pawn to d5 and then after white
takes on d5 and black recaptures on d5
you may be familiar with the fried liver
attack which right away plays Knight two
takes on f7 sacrificing and after the
King comes to f7 then white tries to
chase the King around playing Queen Tate
Queen to f3 check but the lowly attack
actually tries to get the rook involved
into the game and so it goes ahead and
sacrifices a pawn here it plays pawn to
d4 and the variation that we're going to
be looking at is after black takes on d4
now black does have some different
options he does not have to take right
away here on d4 but a lot of the same
concepts that we're going to be going
over in the four main variations after
he does take will pretty much be the
same so I do want to kind of go over the
four variations from here and that is
first after white castles on the King
side again really looking forward to get
this rook involved into the game so
she wants to bring the rook to e1 really
a strong attack that the fried liver
attack doesn't always get to so keep
that in mind the four variations that we
are going to be going over for black
because you may see a lot of different
variations again there's a lot of
attacking going on a lot of tactical
variations in this but I do want to go
over the four main lines that you may
see
the first one is Bishop to b4 again
symbol development move trying to get
the dark square Bishop involved into the
game we'll talk about the pros and cons
of all of these second you may see
Bishop to e7 again trying to block the
rook coming to e1 with tempo checking
the King there on e8 also you may see
Bishop to e6 very important trying to
hold down on this f7 Square huge
weakness for black early on and then the
last one that you may see is pawn to f6
trying to attack this this night here on
g5 so those are the four variations that
we're going to be going over today now
if you're kind of watching this video
and you're like Kevin this is too crazy
off-the-wall no one at top level play
would ever play this it actually has
been played a you know quite a few
number of times and what's surprising is
white pretty much has a phenomenal win
rate so if you're looking for something
as you'll see a lot of times we're going
to be sacrificing this night here on f7
if you're like ah you know sacrificing
pieces early on isn't that great even
you know engines actually score this
really well even after you know big
sacrifices a lot of these variations we
actually sacrifice a night here on c3 so
even with all these you know crazy
sacrifices it's still good because of
all the attacking that white has in his
option so just keep that in mind while
we're going along which is not some
crazy opening that actually doesn't
score well it's actually fundamentally
sound even though we're giving up
material but it really focuses on what
is chess and that is it's not always
about how many pieces you have or what
material you have it's about attacking
your opponent's key if you have a strong
attack on your opponent's king you know
a lot of times that
is more than any means more than
anything else so we'll go ahead and jump
into it
first variation again we're going to
talk about is Bishop to b4 and then
white from here is just going to kick
that away it's kind of an annoying move
but you know every now and then you may
see it and why she's going to play pawn
to a 3 and then the bishops going to
come back to e7 now he could always come
back to a5 but then white can just play
pawn to b4 again attacking it again and
really this Bishop needs to be into the
action he needs to come back to e7 or
he's going to be kind of left out in the
cold while this King just gets a you
know attacked over and over again so he
actually needs to come back to e7 and
this will go into the second variation
we'll get into but the bishops going to
be coming back to even and then the
Knights going to come to f7 so very
similar in the fried liver attack white
is going to be sacrificing a night here
on f7 and then after the King takes on
f7 then the Queen comes to f3 but as you
can tell slight difference in the fried
liver attack and the lily attack we have
Castle down the King side White has and
very easy to get this rook involved into
the game if he ever needs to come to e
wants so just keep that in mind a slight
difference in the two openings now black
has two main options from here one is
just to bring his Bishop to f6 again
blocking this Queen here from attacking
the other one is to bring his King down
to e6 defending this Knight here on the
5 first we're going to go over is Bishop
to f6 probably the better of the two
moves even though right away the white
bishop can take here on d5 attacking the
King here from here you might see black
come to e6 and after the bishops trade
off right here then the rooks going to
come to e1 again a very important
concept in the lowly attack is bringing
this rook to e1 again the white King is
very very safe it's going to be very
hard for black to ever have a attack
against the White King and if you look
at the board White has a strong attack
against the King same was at the fried
liver attack as the lowly attack is both
times White's going to be chasing the
black King around the board it's going
to be very easy to develop pieces into
the game for white at the same time
usually gaining a tempo attacking the
King and also in the middle of the board
anytime your opponent's king is in the
middle of a board it's going to be a
very very good game for you so just keep
that in mind that is one variation also
instead of the bishop coming to f6
the King can also come to be six so I do
feel like this is the the worst of the
two moves from here why it's just going
to play rook to e1 again lowly attack
this is kind of what we're aiming for
eyeing down on this efile this is again
why white gave up this pawn on d4 to get
rid of the black pawn that was here on
e5 to open up this Aoife for our rook
that would later come to e1 right here
so from here the knight can come to e5
and then white is going to play Bishop
to f4 again pinning down this night here
on e5 it can't move
keep him hunting this night here on d5
cannot move also so white is pretty much
developing all his pieces towards the
center of the board he's controlling
this efile and none of these Knights can
move for black so blacks King is in the
middle of the board he doesn't have any
of his major pieces developed it's going
to be really hard for him to move
because pretty much all his pieces are
locked down right now now black could
try to play Bishop
to f6 again trying to defend this night
here on e5 again this is how we talked
about before the bishop is actually uh
you know actually helping if it was here
on e7
whereas if it was over here on a 5 and
the pawn was here on before was kind of
blocking it off into Bishop wasn't doing
anything so definitely helpful if the
bishop is over here on e7
but right here trying to defend this
night here on e5 but now White has a
phenomenal move he can actually just
play Knight to c3 this is kind of what
we
talked about before and that's
sacrificing this night here on c3
typically it doesn't have a a strong
presence in the loli attack a lot of
times it just opens up this D file is
kind of what we're going for and so
after the pawn takes on c3 then white
can go ahead and jump ahead and take
with his rook here on e5 now after the
bishop takes a white can now bring his
rook over to e1 and he's going to have a
very very strong attack right here now
if you look at it you're like well you
know black is actually up in material
this is true but if you look at it this
rook here on h8 isn't moving he's not
doing anything the rook here on a 8 is
not doing anything the Queen here on d8
has not moved yet he's not really
involved into the action this bishop
here on c8 it's going to be very hard
for him to get into the action this
night here on d5 can't move this bishop
here on on e5 can't move and the king is
in the middle of the board so if you
were to run this through an engine White
has an overwhelming dominance on this
game he's pretty much controlling the
zoom of the board and he has so many
different attacks that he can run
against black it's going to be very hard
for black to actually last much longer
in the game so very very powerful attack
again sacrificing not only a night here
on f7 but also sacrificing another night
here on c3 which kind of a common theme
that you'll see in the loli attack now
the next variation we're going to go
over just briefly and that is because it
was Bishop to e7 again this is very very
similar to the last one the only
difference in being that you know if he
comes to b4 first then the pawn comes to
a3 which actually feel like is a bonus
later on the knight may want to come to
b4 as an outpost so pretty much the same
thing is going to happen before if the
bishop comes to e7 first again why it's
going to continue with the same moves
he's going to first come to use me is
going to come to Knight to f7 sacrifice
after the King comes the knight to f7
and recapture the knight then the
Queen's going
come and continue the same thing so just
keep that in mind
Bishop to b4 and then back to e 7 or if
it just comes to e 7 right away
it's going to be very very similar move
so if we come back here instead of
Bishop to e7 you may also see Bishop to
e6 seems like a logical move if you look
at it again so many times white actually
wants to come to f7 right away and
sacrifice and then the king is forced to
you know take well he's not forced but
you know he obviously wants to take here
on f7 gaining material if he doesn't his
Kings just going to be in the middle of
the board and obviously White has the
rook here coming to e1 so after the King
takes on f7 then you know the attack is
very very strong for white so a lot of
times from black you will see this
Bishop come to e6 first which personally
I feel like is the best move for black I
really don't recommend getting into the
lowly attack at all just because White
has such a strong attack but if you ever
do find yourself here and you do have to
choose between one of the variations I
feel like Bishop to e6 probably is the
easiest to play from here White's going
to play rook to e1 again pinning down
this bishop here to the King here so so
now the knight could easily come to f7
and take because the bishop can no
longer recapture on f7 which is kind of
what white is going for the Queen can
now come to the seven again attacking
and defending this pawn here on f7 but
white can pretty much just disregard
that and he can continue in playing
Knight two takes on f7 now if the Queen
takes we already talked about the bishop
can't take but if the Queen takes on f7
then you know the bishop could still
come and take here on d4 again this
Bishop is pinned down to the King he
can't do anything right here so again
very very strong attack a lot of times
you will not see the Queen take but
instead you will see obviously because
that's the same in material but again a
lot of times you may see the King come
to f7 and take and now the Queen is
going to come to f3 as we talked about
before
and now if the King comes back to g8 now
the rook is actually going to come and
capture that bishop here on e6 and this
is a very important part in in the
variation to look at black really needs
to allow this to go if he tries to push
further and actually take this rook here
on e6 then why can come in and capture
with his Queen on d5 black cannot
recapture with his Queen if he does it's
going to be checkmate right away as you
can see from there the best move that
pretty much he has is he can play he can
try you know pawns who h6 if he wants to
and then after the Queen takes the King
goes to h7 the bishop comes down to d3
check and then after g6 it's going to be
checkmate and all over so if we look at
this black really should not take here
on e6 because he's either going to lose
his queen or he's going to lose the game
so just keep that in mind
so rook coming to e6 very very important
part of this and again it's going to be
very very hard for black keep in mind as
we're going through all these variations
there's no really good variation for
black I know I said I kind of prefer
this one but pretty much all four of
these variations scores so much better
for white why does has so much more
opportunity to attack tactical lines are
all in the favour for white White's King
is just kind of hanging out here on g1
again it's going to be so hard for black
to attack and white very similar to the
fried liver attack is just chasing the
black King all around the board so very
very strong again if you if you can not
get into the lowly attack is black I
highly recommend it because it's very
very frustrating and difficult to find
your way out of you know the bombardment
that that white has attacking your King
over and over again so the last
variation that we're going to be going
over is actually not moving one of the
bishops at all but it's actually going
to be bringing the pawn to
f6o very logical move attacking this
night here on excuse me on g5 and and no
longer allowing you know the night to
come here on f7 and then the Queen to
come to f3 attacking the king right away
because there is now this pawn here on
f6 now after pawn to f6 from black-white
now has another opportunity to sacrifice
a night here on c3 so a fantastic move
again white in the lowly attack really
does not use this Knight here that
starts on b1 so anytime that he can
sacrifice this and open up this D file
it's actually a very good opportunity
for white kind of opens up a lines for
his other pieces really opens up the
door forward very strong attack so after
the pawn takes on c3 the bishop for
White's going to take here on d5 and
blacks going to gobble up another night
here White's lost both of his knights
but now White's going to bring his rook
over to e one and attack be king here on
e8 now black could easily come to e7
again defending the King here on e8 and
then white can play Bishop takes on g5
again you know developing his pieces
with tempo so he's got his bishop
involved into the game all of whites
pieces are involved into the game - this
rook here on a1 which he will later on
this rook on h8 is not doing anything
that's rook on a 8s not doing anything
this light square bishop is not doing a
whole heck of a lot and this black King
on e8 is still kind of out in the open
he hasn't castled yet so he's not safe
yet so white has a very very strong
attack right here also as you can tell
this Bishop is now pinned down and we
are attacking the pin down piece anytime
you have a piece that's pinned down it's
a good idea to attack that piece so from
here you may see black has a latch
last-ditch effort you may try to take
here on b2 attacking the rook here and
why can
pretty much just continue with his plan
he can take here on c6 attacking the
king here blacks going to double up his
pawns he needs to take here on c6 and
then white can take with his queen on d8
and after the King takes on d8 again the
King can no longer castle for black why
can come in capture with his bishop on
e7 again with all those sacrificing that
white did with both of his knights as
you can see as far as material
standpoint black is up one pawn which
whites going to get that back
very very soon it would actually be a
mistake if the king came to d7 after the
rook came over to d1
this would be very very bad for black
but a lot of times you may see the King
come back to e8 and then the bishop you
know he can just come back to a3 if you
wanted to a discovered attack with his
rook here on e one and he's also
attacking this pawn here on b2 so he's
going to get that material back also the
King here is still out in the middle
he's out in the open
easy for attacks so you know that the
King could come to f7 and the rook could
come to e7 if you wanted to again
attacking this King here on f7 and also
this pawn here on c7 so a lot of
different attacks that white has wall
black still has a lot that he needs to
do to get his pieces developed into the
game again neither of his rooks have
moved his bishop still is not moved so
white has a distinct advantage as far as
going into the endgame so just keep this
in mind these are the four main
variations again Bishop to b4 Bishop to
e7 Bishop to e6 trying to hold on to
that f7 pawn and then lastly just pawn
to f6 moving forward these are a lot of
the ideas that you'll see in the lowly
attack after if we come back here after
white takes and then the knight takes
and then the pawn comes forward to d4
and black captures you
on d4 so if I get a lot of positive
feedback about the loli attack people
are using it and enjoying it again I
think it's a fantastic opening for white
a lot of different fantastic opening
attacking ideas that white has
especially after he castles on the King
side and gets his rooked involved into
the game again very similar to the fried
liver attack if I get a lot of feedback
if you guys want another video or two
over different variations again you know
black doesn't have to take with this
pawn here on d4 he could always get his
Bishop involvement to the game he could
always take with his night here on d4 so
he definitely has some options feel free
to give me feedback if you guys want to
see that or any other videos that you
get want to see hopefully you enjoy the
loli attack feel free to give it a try
let me know how it goes I think it's
fantastic opening and I think you'll
really enjoy it be sure and check out
the website the chess website calm and
I'll see you guys in the next video
thanks for watching